Labor's Deputy leader Angela Rena is
with us on the program this morning
um morning lots to talk about Ms Rena
thanks for joining us good morning to
you
um what would you say first of all to
the director general of the BBC this
morning
well first of all they need to be very
transparent about their policies
procedures and what they're doing and
how they're you know working how they
would conduct themselves so people have
that confidence that they're dealing
with their complaints so people
understand their complaints process I
think people need to understand of
course they can't give details of
individual campaigns but they're
overarching how do we deal with
complaints I think needs to be explained
so that people have that confidence
because every employer has those
procedures but people have to have
confidence that they're working
correctly and that they're being
followed have you lost confidence in
them given what we've learned so far I
mean I have got the detail to see what's
happened of course the police have
investigating said there was no
criminality there and and it's a
different it's a different bar but that
the BBC have said that they're carrying
out their investigations and that they
need to be able to do that but I would
say being transparent about how your
processes work so people understand that
there is a process and how that operates
I think would help in terms of giving
people confidence that they are robust
in the way they deal with these
complaints Stuart Purvis who used to be
in charge at ITN was that where you were
in the last hour and he said a mother a
worried mother went into the BBC to say
I need help and she left without
receiving it and he he thinks there are
questions to answer there yeah I mean I
don't know the circumstances of how that
was approached but it's pretty clear
from what's being said in the news that
you've got parents and a child that are
at odds with each other which is
incredibly tragic and you've also now
got a presenter who is very very unwell
and in hospital and we do not know the
circumstances around what's happened and
I think that process needs to continue
and it has to be done in the in the
correct manner what would you say to the
editor of the son this one
you know that they have responsibilities
of course it's important that the media
are able to to carry out their their job
and to hold people to account but comes
but what comes with that is
responsibility as well and I think you
know they have responsibilities to
ensure that they're working in an
ethical way to ensure that they're
protecting you know they're doing their
job in terms of you know bringing
stories forward but also that they're
acting in an ethical way and we have
standards that they have to adhere to do
you think they are uh I don't think that
the
I don't know at the moment that we need
to understand the full details of how
that came about and what's been said I
mean that it's still an ongoing process
and more details are coming out every
day at the moment and I think you know
there is a concern here about privacy as
well and protecting people in that
process and and
put plain out in the media is not
necessarily the best way of doing that
but do you not think it's a matter of
public interest if as transpires that um
you know a National Treasure
um a 61 year old man goes on to a
website
um dating app and and gets pictures of a
boy and his team
well I think you know again those those
complaints and and the way in which
that's dealt those are the facts I mean
with the sun right I I I don't know what
the facts are if they're around that
whether or not you know if if two
consenting adults have decided to
conduct themselves in a consenting way
then is that in the public interest then
to put that out I I don't know the full
details there's been there's been
allegations against somebody being
vulnerable Etc and I don't know the full
circumstances to that what would it
happen if it was an MP well it would
clearly end up in the media if it was an
MP but should it I think you know some
things you know it's a question of is it
too consent in adults and is that in the
public interest to put that out is it a
power imbalance you know the I don't
know the circumstances to to the
relationship you know we've heard from
the young person who has put out a
statement through their lawyers uh which
is is different to what the the parents
are saying and you know you've also got
a presenter here who hasn't made a
comment because he's very well and is
receiving medical treatment so I I don't
know the full size
with everyone involved you know the
family you've got parents who are
clearly concerned in our odds with their
their child you've got a young person
who is clearly uh in a different place
and and trying to put their case forward
and you've got a presenter who has not
done anything criminally wrong who has
been you know hounded at the moment to
the point where they're in hospital
they're really unwell
so I think that you know these processes
that the BBC follow and the police who
have conducted their investigation as
well is correct and that needs to happen
uh you know and I think that's important
that there's privacy for people around
that as well would you like to see Hugh
Edwards on screen again
I I want to see him well I want to see
him well and I want to see him have the
opportunity to represent himself in a
far more process where there is
confidence that he will get the
opportunity to put his case forward then
everybody has that right to be able to
do that and at the moment clearly he's
not in a position to do that that's
certainly the case that's certainly the
case
um our latest Westminster account story
I don't know if you've seen the latest
one
um that's that I've seen a bit yes yeah
I just wondered what your thoughts were
on that and how money is being used well
I think again the public are going to be
exasperated with this because it
frustrates them that they're seeing as
they see it wrong doing and there is
clearly a case for him to answer you
know he's the former chairman of the
conservative party Jake Berry and every
time these allegations come forward and
it and it it just undermines people
trust and confidence in elected
politicians which again is why I'm
pushing my independent ethics and
integrity Commission because something
has to be done so that people realize
that you know wrongdoing happens of
course it does but that they have
confidence as a process that a tries to
stop it and prevent it but also that
people are held to account when they
when it does happen and at the moment
people don't have that and we're having
this trickle effect of constant sleaze
and Scandal and it undermines
um trust and confidence in our
politicians a majority of politicians
regardless of political party I believe
go in there for all of the right reasons
and we've just got to make sure that
those bad apples are dealt with and
dealt with swiftly a pair reviewbody
likely to say recommending six six and a
half percent for teachers NHS workers
other public sector workers would labor
agree to that well we'd have to look at
that we're not in government at the
moment we've got our physical just
acceptance we we we're not in government
so we we can't we don't know what the
that what what those negotiations are
going to look like in the future but the
government are not getting around the
table and they're not negotiating we've
got the strike action in the NHS and
this has been going on for a long time
you wouldn't necessarily accept the
independent pay review bodies findings
we'd have to look at it that's what we
did the point of having otherwise Well
we'd look at it and then we'd start the
negotiations and we would do that in
good faith and I think that's the right
way to approach it the alternate at the
moment is that we haven't have a
government that is negotiating we've had
industrial action that perversely is
costing more money as well as creating
more problems for patients who can't get
the care that they want okay I I just
wanted to ask you about a row that is
has been bubbling and you'll have a view
on this with Carol vorderman and the
Mercers I think they're arguing on
Twitter about nonsense but then Carol
vorderman did tweet this she said
um not a degree in sight in spite of
expensive private education so who'd
employ them I mean do you need a degree
to be successful in politics no you
don't need the degree to be successful
in politics because I haven't got one
yeah of course
um but you know I don't I don't think
you need a degree to be successful in
politics but I think Carol's right to
argue that if you've been to you know
you've been privately educated and
you've not been able to get a degree I
mean why waste your money on private
education I mean I personally think that
the state sector is a fantastic sector
they did a great job with me I had a lot
of challenges because I grew up in
poverty and wasn't School ready so it
wasn't my teacher's fault that I left
without any qualifications but look how
resilient I am you know they taught me
some great life skills and I think you
know the states had to do a fantastic
job so don't waste your money on private
schooling you could do just as good in
our state sector and we should celebrate
that so Carol's right to tweet
Washington well Cowell's entitled to her
opinion and think that we all need to be
a bit Kinder on Twitter is what I would
say do you agree with them I I think
that you know she's made a point against
what the nurses are doing and that
that's between Carol and the nurses I'm
not getting involved in that spot
I have enough problems on my own social
media feed it's good to see you thank
you thank you as much appreciated